i found the leap of faith really
interesting in the
so in the technological space so of um
i've i've talked to on this thing with
elon musk but i think he's also just in
general for our culture a really
important figure oh absolutely that
takes uh
i mean he's sometimes a little bit
insane on on
social media on and just in life when i
met him was kind of interesting
that uh of course there's a i mean he's
a
legit engineer so he's fun to talk to
about the technical things
yeah but he also just just the way
the humor and the way he sees life
it just like refuses to be conventional
yeah so it's a constant uh
leap into the unknown and one of the
things that he does
and this isn't even this isn't even like
fake a lot of people say because he's a
ceo there's a business owner so
he's trying to make money no i think
this is this is as
i looked him in in his eyes i mean this
is real
is a lot of the things he believes that
are going to be accomplished that a lot
of others are saying
are impossible like autonomous vehicles
he truly believes it
to me that is the leap of faith of on
what was going like
we're like the the entirety of our
experience is shrouded in mystery yeah
we don't know what the hell's gonna
happen
what you don't know what we're actually
capable of as human beings and he just
takes the leap
he fully believes that we can you know
we can go to
we can colonize mars i mean how could
how crazy is it to just believe
and dream and actually be taking steps
towards it
yeah um to colonizing mars when most
people are like that's the stupidest
idea ever
yeah well i'm in agreement with you on
that um
you know two things you know one is it
reminds me of ben franklin who
in his autobiography you know has
a similarly childish in the best
sense of the word um unbridled
imagination for what might become
you know ben franklin's like yeah i i
got electricity
that's cool but we'll be levitating soon
and i we can't even begin to imagine
uh what we are capable of and of course
people are like dude
that's crazy and there's a guy let's
it's
fcs schiller some humanistic guy at the
beginning of the
20th century he's like you know
um lots of things that
people think about may appear to be
absurd to the point of obscene
but the reality is historically
every fantastic innovation has
generally been initiated by someone who
was condemned
for being a lunatic and
it's not that anything is possible but
surely
things that we don't try will never
manifest as possibilities
yeah and that that's that's uh
that there's something beautiful to that
that's the
uh embracing the abyss and again it's
like the
uh it's the uh embracing the fear of
death the
the the the reality of death and then
turning
uh and to look at all the opportunities
that's right
you